[Música]
el grupo de Mercenario rusos Wagner
asegura estar a un kilómetro del centro
de batmut el ejército ucraniano resiste
en el oeste de la ciudad con el objetivo
declarado de ganar tiempo y desgastar
las tropas rusas a la espera de poder
lanzar una contraofensiva
manifestantes de hacer bailán bloquean
desde hace tres meses la única carretera
que une el nagorno caravag con Armenia
como consecuencia la región disputada
entre baku y ereván enfrenta una crisis
de suministros denunciada por amnistía
internacional
Hollywood se alista para la gala número
95 de los premios Oscar que se celebra
esta noche en esta edición los
asistentes desfilarán por una alfombra
que cambia el rojo por el color champán
y como gran favorita la película todo a
la vez en todas partes tenemos análisis
en esta edición
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de France 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
Mateo y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
abrimos esta edición con información de
Ucrania porque uno de los focos de la
guerra continúa siendo Back mood en el
donbas por un lado el grupo de
Mercenario rusos Wagner reitera que se
acerca cada vez más al centro de la
ciudad por otro lado el ejército
ucraniano asegura que resiste en el
flanco occidental para ganar tiempo
acumular reservistas y armamento y
desgastar a las tropas de Moscú mientras
se prepara para poder lanzar la
contraofensiva recordemos que la batalla
de badmud dura desde agosto y es una de
las más largas y mortales de esta guerra
ruinas hasta donde alcanza la vista es
todo lo que queda debajo una ciudad
industrial de 70.000 habitantes antes de
la guerra desde este verano rusos y
ucranianos luchan encarnizadamente por
su control las fuerzas de kiev afirman
haber matado herido a más de 500
soldados enemigos en la zona en las
últimas 24 horas la batalla de bajo mud
es también una batalla de comunicación
el grupo paramilitar ruso Wagner en
primera línea de los combates Afirma
estar más cerca que nunca del centro de
la ciudad
el edificio de cinco plantas a la
derecha de donde sale el humo es el
centro administrativo de la ciudad
estamos a 1,2 kilómetros de ese edificio
Aunque la importancia estratégica debajo
Es cuestionable según los expertos
militares el Ministerio de defensa
ucraniano quiere mantener el control
sobre la ciudad con la estrategia de
concentrar los esfuerzos rusos en una
parte específica del frente es necesario
ganar tiempo para acumular reservas y
lanzar una contraofensiva en la
primavera que está por llegar Aunque es
el centro de atención la guerra también
continúa en el sur de Ucrania este
sábado en gerson un ataque ruso mató a
tres personas e hirió a otras dos en
otras noticias manifestantes de
azerbaiyán bloquean desde hace tres
meses la única carretera que conecta el
nagorno caravag con Armenia lo que ha
provocado una situación de escasez de
alimentos y medicinas en la región
disputada entre Armenia y azerbaiyán
recordemos que cerca de 120.000 armenios
viven en el nagorno caravag dentro de un
territorio reconocido internacionalmente
como parte de azerbaiyán según amnistía
internacional la situación humanitaria
Es catastrófica y reporteros Sin
fronteras pide azerbaiyán y a las
fuerzas rusas se inició en misión de paz
que dejen pasar a los periodistas
Esta es la única carretera que une la
región de nagorno carabach con Armenia
desde hace tres meses el corredor de la
chin está bloqueado por un grupo de
manifestantes aceríes afirman estar aquí
para protestar contra la minería ilegal
en el enclave poblado en su mayoría por
personas de origen armenio la versión de
erevan es bien distinta estos
manifestantes estarían apoyados por las
autoridades aceríes que de este modo
pondrían en marcha indirectamente una
operación de limpieza étnica el bloqueo
ha provocado importantes carencias en
naborno caravag
qué podemos hacer al respecto por
supuesto es difícil no tenemos gas y se
producen cortes de Electricidad como
regularidad los ancianos conseguimos
sobrevivir pero lo siento por nuestros
hijos
durante la Guerra de otoño de 2020
azerbaiyán tomó el control de varios
territorios armenios entre ellos varios
alrededor de nagorno carabaj un negocio
entonces un alto el fuego y se
desplegaron tropas rusas en la zona el
mes pasado el tribunal Internacional de
Justicia ordenó a bakú que garantizará
la libre circulación de bienes y
personas a través del corredor
la interrupción del tráfico en el
corredor de la chin impidió que las
personas de origen armenio
hospitalizadas en adorno fueran
trasladadas a centros médicos de Armenia
para recibir tratamiento de urgencia
las pruebas también demuestran que hubo
obstáculos a la importación de productos
de primera necesidad anagorno caravag lo
que provocó escasez de alimentos
medicinas y otros suministros médicos
vitales
sin embargo la cif rechazó la petición
de Armenia de ordenar a azerbaiyán que
dejara de organizar manifestaciones y
permitiera el flujo de gas natural al
enclave por su parte las autoridades de
bakú niegan que exista un bloqueo total
en el corredor de la China y que haya
una crisis humanitaria en la región
en Israel el Primer Ministro Benjamín
netanyahu felicitó al ejército por haber
matado a tres palestinos que
presuntamente habrían atacado un puesto
de control en cisjordania ocupada
recordemos que desde principios de año
ya han muerto 80 palestinos en
incursiones israelíes más detalles con
Luis Muñoz
en este punto han muerto tres palestinos
el ejército israelí disparó contra ellos
y detuvo un cuarto aseguran que iban
armados el Primer Ministro Benjamín
netanyahu se alegró por estas muertes me
gustaría felicitar a los combatientes de
golán y que eliminaron a tres
terroristas en samaria como todos
podemos ver nuestras fuerzas están
operando las 24 horas del día contra
aquellos que buscan matarnos el
principio es simple cualquiera que
intente hacernos daño o nos hace daño
pagará el precio el suceso fue cerca de
naplusa en el norte de cisjordania una
zona en disputa donde Palestina quiere
construir su estado
los jóvenes muertos pertenecían a la
brigada de Mártires de alaxa una rama
armada del partido fata del presidente
de la autoridad Palestina mahamutaás las
familias quieren despedirse de sus hijos
entonces si ellos tienen a nuestros
hijos los queremos No pedimos nada más
queremos que nuestros hijos estén aquí
que los podamos enterrar Y poder volver
a verlos
desde principios de año 80 palestinos
han sido asesinados en operativos
israelíes en 2022 fueron cerca de 150 en
el año más letal desde 2004
las incursiones de Israel son cada vez
más frecuentes en un endurecimiento del
gobierno más a la extrema derecha en 55
años un conflicto sin resolver desde que
en 1967 Israel invadiesecis Jordania la
franja de gaza y el este de Jerusalén en
la guerra de medio oriente
y España atraviesa una ola de calor sin
precedentes en esta época del año desde
que se tienen registros recordemos que
en el hemisferio norte todavía es
invierno y sin embargo este domingo en
varios puntos de la costa del
Mediterráneo las temperaturas llegaron a
30 grados Celsius unos 10 puntos por
encima de lo que es habitual en marzo
según reportó la agencia española de
meteorología el inusual calor también
dio lugar a imágenes inusuales para esta
época Y es que decenas de personas se
bañaron en el mar al tiempo que la
preocupación sobre la desregulación y la
emergencia climática es cada vez mayor
y el gobierno de India se opone al
reconocimiento de los matrimonios entre
personas del mismo género esto según ha
manifestado en un escrito presentado
este domingo ante el tribunal supremo y
al que ha tenido acceso la agencia
reuters Y es que este lunes el tribunal
supremo de la India empezará a estudiar
la legislación del matrimonio
igualitario
en India mientras la comunidad lgbti se
enfrenta a un hito en el reconocimiento
de sus derechos el Ministerio de
Justicia remitió una petición al
tribunal supremo manifestando su
objeción al matrimonio entre personas de
mismo sexo el documento fue revisado por
la agencia de noticias reuters el
Ministerio de Justicia cree que aunque
pueda haber varias formas de relaciones
en la sociedad el reconocimiento legal
del matrimonio es para las relaciones
heterosexuales y el estado tiene un
interés legítimo en mantenerlo así la
convivencia en pareja y las relaciones
sexuales entre personas del mismo sexo
no son equivalentes con el concepto de
India de unidad familiar entre marido
mujer e hijos cinco años después de
despenalizar las relaciones homosexuales
el tribunal supremo de India escuchará a
varias personas que solicitan el
reconocimiento oficial del matrimonio
entre personas del mismo
sexong y sufrío shakra borchi están
entre los demandantes se casaron en 2021
pero su Unión no está oficialmente
reconocida lo que dificulta su vida
cotidiana sí
somos pareja desde hace más de 10 años
Somos las personas más importantes en la
vida del otro Sin embargo a los ojos de
la ley no somos nadie solo somos
extraños
mañana si me pasa algo y estoy en el
hospital y Alguien tiene que tomar
decisiones médicas él no tendría derecho
a hacerlo a ojos de la ley si los
demandantes se imponen India sería el
segundo país asiático después de Taiwán
en reconocer patrimonio entre personas
del mismo sexo y cerramos con cine
porque en Los Ángeles se celebra esta
noche la gala número 95 de los premios
Oscar la cita anual más emblemática de
la industria de Hollywood y para
analizar Cómo se presenta esta edición
Contamos con la periodista especializada
en cine muralla mullor Mireia Buenas
tardes para usted un gusto saludarla
desde los estudios de france24 como
decíamos esta es la cita más emblemática
Quizás de Hollywood pero la audiencia
que congrega es muy menor a la de por
ejemplo hace una década qué peso tiene
hoy en día esta ceremonia Y qué
particularidades presenta el espectáculo
de esta noche
Hola Rosa sí está claro que las
audiencias de los oscars han ido bajando
progresivamente está claro Aunque
tenemos que decir que el año pasado hubo
un 50% de aumento de la audiencia por
supuesto debemos achacarlo al gran
momento que se vivió con Will Smith
dándole un puñetazo a Chris Rock en
directo obviamente esto es un tema
excepcional que subir las audiencias en
ese momento Y seguramente afectó pero
está claro que el descenso es Claro que
no son las mismas audiencias que se
tenían hace 10 20 años aunque también
hay que decir que el interés de la gente
por los oscas puede manifestarse de
otras maneras diferentes a simplemente
ponerse la televisión la noche de los
oscars y verlo en directo se puede
seguir por redes sociales se puede
seguir de muchas otras maneras no
Entonces yo creo que la relevancia sigue
ahí más allá de los datos de audiencia Y
Mireia esta noche hay una Clara favorita
se trata de la película todo a la vez en
todas partes todo al mismo tiempo en
todas partes disculpa cuál es la clave
el éxito de esta película y se espera
que ya lo tenga todo ganado o ahí puede
haber Alguna sorpresa
es un título enrevesado toda la vez en
todas partes Sí desde luego es la gran
favorita además se ha convertido en la
favorita de una manera meteórica en el
último mes ha arrasado en Premios muy
importantes de los gremios de actores de
directores de productores
el tipo de premios que se que ayudan a
predecir qué es lo que va a ocurrir en
los osos entonces la película de Los
Daniels cuenta con premios muy
importantes como favorita como es el de
Michelle Yo como como mejor actriz que
cual como mejor actor de reparto cuenta
con un éxito de aquí ya que también es
muy importante y que también seguramente
estará en mente de los académicos que
quieren convertir a los oscars en algo
Como decíamos aún más relevante o algo
que pueda apelar a más audiencias no
entonces parte con 11 nominaciones es
una película que podría ganar a mejor
película Aunque tenemos que recordar que
la categoría de mejor película no se
cuenta de la misma manera que el resto
de categorías donde quien más votos
tiene gana no en mejor película Ahí lo
que conocemos como el voto preferencial
lo que quiere decir que las películas
que tienen más consenso son las que más
podrían llevarse el premio en lugar de
las que crean División y todo a la vez
en todas partes yo creo que cae más en
un poco una división de opiniones una
división de tendencias por parte de la
academia aún así Creo que que sigue
siendo la favorita Y sí yo creo que se
acabará llegando el gato al agua y media
hablemos de otra película ahora
Argentina 1985 y la gran apuesta de
América Latina que están nominada a
mejor película extranjera Cómo se lee
las nominaciones de esta categoría
bueno esta categoría a mí siempre me ha
parecido increíble porque al final son
las mejores películas o las películas
escogidas por cada país para
representarles y realmente el nivel
siempre es espectacular el nivel de esta
categoría este año es espectacular
Argentina 1985 es una película muy
importante Yo diría que tiene
posibilidades de llevárselo se llevó el
globo de oro a mejor película extranjera
se llevó también el Goya aunque esto no
no tiene nada que ver con los oscars
pero es una película que ha recogido
premios y que ha tenido muy buena
crítica sin embargo yo creo que la
favorita en esta categoría va a ser Sin
novedad en el frente la película alemana
es una película que parte con nueve
nominaciones en los oscars que
seguramente se va a llegar alguna
estatuilla técnica entonces parte como
favorita en esta categoría y bueno
estaremos apostando por Argentina pero
parece que Alemania se llevará se
llevará la estatuilla Mireya Muchísimas
gracias Lamentablemente se nos acaba el
tiempo para continuar analizando esta
gala pero Seguiremos comentándola mañana
una vez conozcamos todos los ganadores
Muchas gracias muchas gracias
y a ustedes llegamos así al final de
esta emisión pero sigan con nosotros y
más información
[Música]